>> WELCOME BACK.
IT’S NOT JUST GOVERNMENT PLANS
AND TAXING THAT WILL FUEL
RECOVERY BUT THE AMERICAN
SPIRIT.
JOINING ME NOW TO JUST ADDRESS
THAT IS FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
RAYMOND.
YOU’VE GOT SOME THOUGHTS ON
THIS, I JUST WILL HAND IT OVER
TO YOU.
GO FOR IT.
>> STEVE, I’VE BEEN REFLECTING
DURING THIS TIME ON OUR
FOUNDING, THE FIRST
REVOLUTION, YOU’RE ALWAYS
CARRYING THE BANTER OF THE
NEXT ONE.
THE FIRST REVOLUTION, THE
SPIRIT OF RECOVERY THAT I
THINK WE’VE MISSED IT
SOMEWHERE ALONG THE WAY IS
FOUND IN OUR PAST.
IN 1775 WHEN GEORGE WASHINGTON
IN OUR FOUNDING FATHER WAS
STRUGGLING FOR INDEPENDENCE IN
BOSTON THERE WAS A SMALLPOX
OUTBREAK.
PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT THIS.
HIS ARMY WAS THREATENED, ALL
OF BOSTON WAS INFECTED WITH
THIS HORRIBLE CONTAGION,
HERE’S WHAT HE DID.
HE QUARANTINED THE SOLDIERS
AND THE BOSTON LOCALS WHO WERE
INFECTED AND THEY MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE SIEGE OF BOSTON SO HE
WAS FIGHTING TO ENEMIES.
THE SMALLPOX AND THE ARMY HE
WAS TRYING TO REPEL.
FORGIVE US STEVE, YOUR
COUNTRYMEN.
THEN WE HAD YELLOW FEVER.
PEOPLE FORGET, ALEXANDER
HAMILTON IN 1793, HE
CONTRACTED YELLOW FEVER IN
PHILADELPHIA.
HE LEFT THE CITY, HE RECOVERED
AND THE FOUNDING FATHERS FOUND
A WAY TO ADAPT.
THEY WERE INNOVATIVE AND TRIED
TO CONTAIN THE CONTAGION THAT
THEY HAD NO THERAPEUTIC AND
VACCINE FOR, THEY EVENTUALLY
INOCULATED THEMSELVES VERY
CRUDELY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
HISTORICAL PATTERN, YELLOW
FEVER IN NEW ORLEANS, 150,000
PEOPLE DIED BETWEEN 1803 IN
THE CIVIL WAR HERE.
BUT WHEN THEODORE ROOSEVELT
CAME, HE SAID NO ORLEANIANS
WERE CREATING GREATER DRAINAGE
SYSTEMS, THEY BUILT THOSE
DRAINAGE SYSTEMS WE HAVE
TODAY, MOSQUITO CONTROL, HE
SAID THEY TOOK HOLD OF IT
AFTER IT HAD STARTED AND THEY
CONTROLLED IT AND CONQUERED
IT.
IT SEEMS TO ME WE HAVE TO HAVE
THAT NOTION TO NOT FOCUS ON
THE CONTAGION BUT ON THE GOAL
OF LIBERTY.
THAT’S WHAT ALWAYS DROVE THESE
GREAT INNOVATIVE AMERICANS
FORWARD, AND IT REMINDED ME OF
JOHN ADAMS WHO HIM HIMSELF
BATTLED SMALLPOX AND HE WROTE
THIS IN 1765, LIBERTY MUST, AT
ALL HAZARDS BE SUPPORTED.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO IT, DERIVED
FROM OUR MAKER, AND IF WE HAD
NOT OUR FATHERS HAVE EARNED IT
AND BOUGHT IT FOR US AT THE
EXPENSE OF THEIR EASE, THEIR
ESTATES, THEIR LEISURE AND
THEIR BLOOD.
TODAY WE ARE WILLING TO TRADE
THAT LIBERTY, I WORRY, FOR A
QUICKIE PIZZA AND A NETFLIX
SUBSCRIPTION.
OUR LIBERTY IS MORE VALUABLE
THAN THAT.
WE HAVE TO STRIVE FOR AND FIND
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO MOVE ON
WITH OUR LIFE.
>> VERY WELL SAID.
YOU ARE REMINDING ME WHAT I
LOVE ABOUT THIS COUNTRY, WHY
I’M SO PROUD TO BE HERE.
LITERALLY WHY I DECIDED TO
BECOME AN AMERICAN CITIZEN,
AND BY THE WAY, I DON’T TAKE
THE OLD BRITISH STUFF
PERSONALLY AT ALL BECAUSE MY
PARENTS WERE HUNGARIAN
IMMIGRANTS, ALL THAT OLD
STUFF, THAT WASN’T MY PEOPLE
SO YOU CAN BE AS RUDE AS YOU’D
LIKE.
>> EXACTLY.
ALL RIGHT.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS BEAUTIFULLY
PUT.
LET’S BRING IN LISA AND
CHARLIE.
LET’S START WITH YOU.
WHAT WERE YOUR REACTIONS.
>> RAYMOND’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE PURSUIT OF LIBERTY IS
PARAMOUNT FOR OUR COUNTRY.
RECENTLY MAYOR GARCETTI SAID
YOU HAVE TO EARN YOUR FREEDOM
BACK.
THINK ABOUT THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF HIM SAYING THAT.
NO, WE HAVE FREEDOM NATURALLY,
WE HAVE NATURAL RIGHTS.
THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT OF OUR
COUNTRY, THAT THE DECLARATION
OF INDEPENDENCE, THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATE OF OUR NATION AND
THE LAWS OF NATURE, IT WAS
SUCH A CATEGORICAL DIFFERENCE
SAYING NO NO, YOU THE
GOVERNMENT WE CREATE YOU AS
HUMAN BEINGS, WE HAVE NATURAL
RIGHTS IN THE STATE OF NATURE
AND WHAT WE SEE RIGHT NOW IS
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO THAT
PURSUIT OF LIBERTY.
AWAY FROM THAT AUTHORITARIAN
TECHNOCRATIC NONSENSE WHERE
THEY SAY TO PEOPLE IN A VOTE,
YOU CAN’T GO ON WET SAND, YOU
CAN NO LONGER SKATEBOARD,
PEOPLE KNOW THIS DOESN’T MAKE
SENSE.
IT’S LIBERTY THAT MADE AMERICA
GREAT.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO IT.
>> LISA, THAT’S RIGHT BUT THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THE ACTUAL
RECOVERY, THAT’S IN THE HANDS
OF STATE AND LOCAL
POLITICIANS, NOT ALL OF WHOM
SHARE THESE VIEWS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I HAVE MORE FAITH IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO EXERCISE
COMMON SENSE THAN I DO ANY OF
THESE POLITICIANS AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS, AND I’M FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE WHAT FRUSTRATES ME SO
MUCH AS SO MANY OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE ARE FACING
ARE SELF-INFLICTED.
THEY ARE DONE BY POLITICIANS
WHO HAVE LOCKED DOWN THE
ECONOMY, PUSHED OFF THINGS
LIKE WHAT WAS NONESSENTIAL
HEALTH SERVICES, AND A LOT OF
THESE POLICIES COULD
EVENTUALLY LEAD TO MORE DEATH
AND DESTRUCTION THAN THE
CORONAVIRUS ITSELF.
FURTHER, I DON’T KNOW ABOUT
YOU BUT I’M SO SICK AND TIRED
OF PEOPLE SAYING THINGS LIKE
WERE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SAYING THAT ARE STILL GETTING
A PAYCHECK WHERE THEY ARE
INDEPENDENTLY WEALTHY, AND
IT’S 36 MILLION AMERICANS WHO
DON’T HAVE JOBS OR THE HUNDRED
THOUSAND BUSINESSES THAT HAD
PERMANENTLY CLOSED IN THE
BUSINESS OWNER HAVING THEIR
DREAMS CRUSHED HER THE MOM AND
DAD HAVING TO GO TO A FOOD
BANK FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THEIR LIFE THAT ARE
SUFFERING.
I FIND MYSELF SO FRUSTRATED,
BUT I AM CONFIDENT WE WILL GET
THROUGH THIS BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE RESILIENT
AND WE ARE STRONG, BUT I HAVE
MORE FAITH IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAN I DO IN ANY OF
THOSE POLITICIANS.
>> RAYMOND, I’M YOU HANDED
OVER TO YOU, BUT ACTUALLY WHAT
READLISA IS TALKING ABOUT,
THAT RIGHTEOUS ANGER IS PART
OF THE AMERICAN STRIKE TWO.
>> WE ARE RAMBUNCTIOUS
PEOPLE.
A DEFIANT PEOPLE WHO WERE SO
COMMITTED TO LIBERTY AND
FREEDOM AND I WORRY WE ARE
TRADING THAT TO STAY AT HOME
IN HIDING.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, AND I LOVE
BEING A NORMAL INDIAN.
YOU SEE THAT SPIRIT COMING
OUT, EVEN
OUT, EVEN THE MAYOR WHO WAS
LOCKING THINGS DOWN, THERE’S
OUTDOOR DINING, PEOPLE ARE
DEVELOPING UV MASKS THAT HAVE
THE UV LIGHT THAT GOES OUT AND
PURIFIES THE AIR ON THE WAY